Vincent's out there chatted up with
Roland yes surprise you can understand
them at all I don't know how he does
yeah I don't know how many guests so
many guests are able to have
conversations with Roland did you
understand what Roland would say that's
a great question Carl if it's so
difficult to understand
Roland Vincent d'Onofrio's here our
Booker nobody kind of talks in a mumbled
way and BA he's great with guests so sit
up there have a 20-minute conversation
was rolling out there yeah have you got
what what is he talking no I was talking
and he was listening and he's a really
good listener he is he's a good listener
because he holds people's attention on
what is he talking about mumbles a lot I
have to get back to you on the talking
aspect of him okay he was just listening
he's a good he's a good very good
listener yeah you'd be make a good
husband I think that's his goal Ashley
yeah you know anything about Roland it's
probably the strategy
well welcome and uh you're going to be
starring in Emerald City yes
premiering tomorrow it's a take on the
Wizard of Oz I know it's tomorrow
so we're we've been waiting so long for
it to come cuz we all worked so hard you
know only when did you shoot it we shot
it last year for Audria oh honey her
name is she was on it for I think seven
or eight months I was on it for five
months that's a major commitment yeah
it's ten hours of content that we shot
all at once like a giant movie Wow with
one director tarsem then war wasn't it
done regionally though with so I wasn't
originally supposed to be done then and
then there was a problem to showrunner
and he wasn't happy with it then they
spent so yeah I didn't have anything to
do with it back then so I don't know the
specifics but yes I heard that but um
this Deezer hey man thanks I was one
year we were asking what you guys were
talking about cuz you're so good with
talking to guests and with us we
understand nothing you say he said
you're a very good listener Roland
he said you're a good listener did you
get your order right hope no listener
just stands there uh-huh
but you did it so you shot it all like
one one long thing yeah yeah any intense
yeah we have to carry around like you
know 10 scripts
also they gave it to you all at once we
were shooting it
out of sequence like you would a movie
yes yeah occasion she shoot all the
stuff in the same location in the same
director it's not like a regular TV show
where right new director doesn't new
script we had all ten of them we had to
read all ten of them and and be able to
reference all ten ten of them on a daily
basis for you yes we do proud do you
memorize like no see you just kind of
get the scene
well I jumped in I thought you're gonna
say do you memorize everything of all
ten hours right you do not you just have
all ten episodes in your head have
what's called the shooting schedule much
like a schedule you guys probably have
here and and you know days in advance
what you're shooting when and and so you
have you usually have two or three days
to get huge scenes under your belt
before you um you know film before you
actually have to do it yeah and we've
read Europe obviously we know about you
and stuff and what is it there's
probably a story that is being told
incorrectly what you turn down some kind
of Sopranos which I know you've talked
about before what was the reason for it
and what was the role that you turned
out god always the rule would you
remember what year it was like was it
the 99 2000 around there you know what I
don't know I don't remember I remember
where I was living where my wife and I
were living and the reason why I turned
down so I would have had to sell my
house to do the show that's amazing
speaking of commitment yeah I know it's
like why would you imagine at your house
edition because we weren't about afford
it like we we were living on Avenue B we
got a really good deal on a apartment
christed or building on Avenue B and uh
but I would have had I couldn't have
worked any other job so that's all the
amount that they were gonna pay me was
just not enough for me to sustain my
life I wouldn't be able to do I would
have to sell my house get an apartment
to be able to afford to live in New York
and in a role like was it like recurring
I was like a once - no I'm trying to
there was an actor that did it who was
really great and was it a cop was that
we really wish Emmy in the show yes yeah
when I was like season that was all
white Tony's cousin that was like B
already really famous by then that was
uh oh yeah I was a working actor yeah
yeah yeah that was in four so that would
have been like that was like an arc that
like a full-season yeah Ark and I guess
just to do that yeah I don't remember
exactly what he said to me chase we
talked on the phone and he he didn't he
didn't us he said a new character he
didn't say anything about how short it
was going to be a long we just said it
was a new character and you know it
wasn't like a big deal it's like they
weren't they weren't terribly upset that
I said no or anything somebody asked me
one day and I like doing like I couldn't
do it I wanted to do it I actually told
him that I said I would love to do this
I just can't afford to do it you're
gonna have to come up a little bit on
the money and I couldn't and they
couldn't and I couldn't because I
literally I'm not kidding I would have
had to change my lifestyle and we were
just going to have we were just going to
have our first my first boy and I
couldn't die did you work right after
full-metal-jacket sorry no like was that
was that light was it hard to see you as
anything but that well I didn't work
until I lost all the weight that I
gained on it and then I did mystic pizza
yeah you went on a string of like pretty
iconic easy mystic pizza you did
adventures in babysitting like all these
movies that kind of do you have any idea
when you're doing a movie like that then
it's gonna live forever like those like
I'd say that those three in that era
absolutely I actually I think I'm
terrible at it actually you don't like
it no I know I like them both of those
movies I like them no I think I'm
terrible at picking things up that you
know I mean honestly I just when I've
changed my reasons for doing stuff when
I was a kid I just used to do it because
either I thought it was really cool or
there were girls involved or or like you
know it was like a challenge like I was
scared of it so maybe I should do it you
know like created a fear and me total so
maybe I should face it and do it but I
changed you know we all grow up and we
become different people so we can so my
reasons for doing stuff now changing and
so I like to say that I'm better at it
now I choose things because of material
because of who's involved and and not
just the the character that I'm playing
but the whole the whole event how long
were you a bodyguard for
Oh for a long a big how tall you looks
for okay you are bigger than I thought
and so you did that before you acted or
why you acted to kind of supplement your
work when I did Full Metal Jacket I went
back to work at the Hard Rock Cafe when
it was on 57th Street back in the day
when Danny Aykroyd owned it and in all
those people for my public just before
it went public and I used to do
bodyguard work so we still doing it so
you doin like for Robert Plant not just
that night but you actually wood wood no
no no there was one night I just did one
morning with him yeah and uh but I used
to do so many people I even did Yul
Brenner on Broadway his last show when
he died I was doing that me and a couple
other guys were doing that show we were
we would watch him all night and go pick
him up and take him home and stuff like
that and as a guy who's like obviously
pursuing acting like were you so into it
that you just wanted to be around it so
that if you weren't acting you could at
least bodyguard and be a part of it or
was it just no I'm not really I would I
see what you're saying no I'm not really
that kind of actor I don't you know you
don't need to be around at all the time
no I I didn't back then either it was
really good money yeah you did you know
how to pass did you know how to fight or
we just a big guy like did you have
training in terms of hand in hand combat
I'm not gonna you're gonna have to
challenge me to find out is that right
I'll just say that I'm not and then if
you want to fight in the back or
something we can what did you have any
do you have anything did you have any
fights when you were doing that or get
something being a big guys a deterrent
and people just only a that you could
you'll ever find out if I actually had
fights is by knowing if I'm a good
fighter and you'd have to fight me to
find that out right I don't want to
fight you know I enjoy it work - I don't
want any bigger you're smaller I don't
want a chick by the way I don't affect
you guys guys I asked know what is
choice I'm gonna just assume whether or
not you're a good fighter just leave it
at that I don't know I don't need to
find out exactly laughs I don't need to
know I don't need to tell you right
exactly
okay well nervous I wanna get hit okay
great story though if you just slap you
in the face and you know happy the fans
would be live have I stepped up to you
yeah let's find out been in this
building before where I wanted to smack
a guy in the face what happened one of
the guys he's not working here anymore
they set me up for this for the Wiener
thing who set you up I don't want to say
their names okay
okay's two of them and they had somebody
kind of provocative so he that was in
this room is sitting next to you when
that happened I was I what happened we I
about Andrew Breitbart was here
you were our guest Andrews guest two in
urban on it was open wasn't in this room
it was a bigger room I know is this from
they've actually changed it oh it's been
redone and what happened was Andrew
Breitbart if anyone didn't know had this
photo of wieners dick that he said he
was never going to release we had never
seen that we had never interviewed
Andrew on this show I just known him
from some nonmetal show on adachi oh
sorry yeah so then we he's passing the
picture around and there was some type
of a Paltalk camera which like a social
interaction thing and it was either oh
poor Anthony had had held it up to the
camera to show them somebody screen
grabbed hmm now none of us knew this in
the room know that nobody set you up
today they really weren't doing it for
that reason we left after that they set
me up you think so Opie and Anthony no
they didn't are they absolutely a
hundred percent wrong I'll tell you why
I went didn't interview with Tom papa
I didn't interview with Tom papa I was
he's a comedian who interviewed me for
something and then I came back out and
then there was all I can't believe those
guys tweeted the picture I can't believe
those guys tweeted that's how I found
out they had tweeted what makes and they
said yeah well because the way they
edited it the the video right it looked
like and they said the headline was that
I came out I brought him out into
trouble whatever it was the online
that's what they did and they they
edited to make it look like I'm the one
that originally said there's a photo of
the penis with Weiner oh I guess that's
then who did the video was that I don't
know Matthew did O'Neill it was like one
of these but I'm sure was the in studio
video yeah but did buddy went edited it
was edited there was like big chunks of
of everybody out of it and and and put
in so that when I have to see it
so I'm sure that I haven't seen he's a
total so what okay just for a little
tiny little blurb saying Vincent
D'Onofrio outs wieners you know someone
who did the press put that out or is out
the video they put out that's I have to
see that on working in tandem no it's
maybe it's the I was set up
look I've been in the business for a
long time I don't have anything to do
with politics right I don't have
anything to do with this guy I didn't
even know who he was dead
yeah I didn't even know who he was
Andrew Berg and so I shouldn't have been
brought into the conversation at all I
was there to promote something else you
really mean it was weird yes we end up
in a scenario where it's like I didn't
sign up back on the stack those ways way
we did a lot of times there was a cross
of guests like a lot of times it would
be it would be the oddest mix of people
yeah I remember why Andrew was in that
day to be on it was the only time we had
him on I think he was in because he had
something on his phone that he wanted to
he didn't want to put that out he was so
mad at me he thought I set him up which
I absolutely didn't dude he dude but he
didn't wanna throw it out he showed us
it showed everybody had passed it around
and the guy hey yeah one of the other
dudes hold it held it up to the cash
Andrew did not know that it was gonna be
hella the kids giggling the whole - you
are asking for it in in in it wasn't
smart but here a few recent he went on
Eliot Spitzer show glad you said it
wasn't smart nobody but what I like him
but I do but I but I was starting to not
like him
and then suddenly he said that and I
like him but he's got a nice smile he
just smiled like thank you he's a sweet
boy but even though even if even if
Breitbart isn't me stupid that doesn't
mean that he was because he was a fairly
honest dude I don't think he did it to
be duped if you want to show the picture
he would have showed it and he would
have controlled an era Dom level you
know no he didn't know because he called
me I called he was furious at me really
he's like you [ __ ] set me up because
you went on Eliot Spitzer show and said
I set him up and I'm like dude I'm not a
liar if I set you up I didn't set you up
and I told him how that picture got
tweeted out he was [ __ ] furious about
I but I did start this conversation with
saying it was those two guys yeah right
they were the ringleaders they knew what
they were doing and that's what bothered
me about it is that I came on to do
their show and they set me up I didn't
see the video you're talking about so I
don't know if that video is edited like
you're saying was that the way
make it look like you were behind it
were part of it that I can't comment not
only the edit and not only the video
looks like that but it actually said
that I did it
like so it was like if you find that
video we should look at that video
because I want to know if that's an
opiate any video or did somebody in the
press grab it and you know how they
[ __ ] clickbait everything so did they
take the story and then make you the
bigger part of the story else I should
have never been there yeah is that all
when as that all is going on you have to
sit there and be like so do it because
you can't like walk out and make a scene
of it right well I didn't want to be
rude but I felt so uh I felt yeah
I felt so detached by it anyway yet was
it was the gut not it was not anti that
open on it absolutely does say yes
you're right no you're right but I'm
saying you appointed the wrong state
your point that see but it wasn't it was
look at that yeah no no he's right he's
right yes that was definitely set up
absolutely now I'm seeing this yep yep
100% and that's his channel so yes
around that correct so the fact that you
wanna let somebody know let's go on the
record just don't hit me so sweet boy
first of all you are a sweet guy thank
you very much and second of all I don't
want to hit anybody
thank you I'm third of all I'm right yes
look about that you were correct you
instant D'Onofrio right again yes yes I
don't again when's the first server
it's a swear I'm so happy you talked
about it so you won't address stuff the
tap but I remember being a very mad when
that happened to shows afraid we're
gonna get fired I said we're gonna get
[ __ ] fired for that yeah and we
didn't I'm selfish so it's it's you you
just you know I'm not like one of those
kind of guys that's gonna like make a
big deal about in fact I've never talked
about it ever until now right you know
right but and the context of like you
well I mean it was just I'm I this room
felt familiar I guess but I know I
understand personally I don't I didn't
realize you were there we met that day
we sat next to each other for a while
but that's the impact I normally have on
people I'm like a flu-like you kind of
you kind of remember me but you're not
sure um but no no that's I don't if
that's why you were pissed off at that
would piss me off to to feel like you
know obviously I wasn't mad pissed off
because it's never been mentioned again
right but still okay yeah it makes sense
I I wanted to do you like because this
project
it's like you said it's not really a
typical series it's it like a 10-hour
it's kind of an event is what they're
portraying it as I don't think is there
any are they only doing the one season
where they going to do another Vava
they'll know okay I don't know like
we'll see we'll see what happens I have
a feeling people are going to really
like it so it'll probably they'll
probably do more but I can't say do you
like series life because obviously
criminal intent was massive and it
becomes one of those things where it's
good steady work but at the same time
people then I think feel like they kind
of know you because they spend so much
time with you and it's every week and
all that stuff yeah i television is
these days --is is not very different
from from any other venue that that you
do as an actor i mean though the theater
is the only thing that's really
different everything else is kind of the
same now because of the way things are
done and so people when I did law and
order when I used to do law and order
you know that's that was the kind of
show where if people a lot of people
didn't like it but a lot of people liked
it people didn't like it there's a lot
of people that didn't like that show but
that's okay because there was a huge
also a huge fan you know huge cult
following list why didn't they like it
was well acted I mean they didn't like
the stories or what would well I think
they had the same problems that I
sometimes had was that it was he was
just way too smart okay you know yeah
but but it is TV and it was sort of
based on like a Sherlock Holmes
character so it was supposed to be like
that and uh but that kind of show makes
you know you're in people's living rooms
and they actually consider you a friend
and so the way that they react to you is
different than like but the people that
were fan the people that are fans of
Bobby Gorn are different than people
that are fans of anything else I've
played yeah they're very much they
really they really consider me close to
them yeah do you what do you think of
that you like that or is that weird you
out or I mean the the ones that I've met
are awesome people yeah you know there's
just no weirdness about them but if I
think you're smart - I mean it's a - my
dad got to be associated with your
genius cop some guy exactly when you're
doing a I've always wondered this men
and black
how much is makeup and how much is you
physically like
like when the alien takes over your body
how much is makeup and how much is you
physically like you know tuck in your
chin back in and well there was only one
scene towards the end of of his body
deteriorating it it he wears I wore a
neck piece to make it look like it was
like all jolly and everything
yeah but up before that it was up until
then it was it was it was all physical
stuff it's amazing I don't know if
you've ever seen it but it really is
like a physical transformation yeah and
you were so much fun I feel like that's
one that people forget was even you yeah
I hope so yeah you know because because
it was such a Rick Baker did all the
makeup and stuff and between him and I
in the chair we developed that over a
month or so so period and came up
together we worked with all the the how
he was going to look the stages that he
went through and Rick was amazing Rick
Baker was amazing he's retired now but
he was like the best in the business
years ago and you're in one of my
favorite movies Ed Wood is a mouthpiece
great and you played Orson Welles in
that and I didn't do the voice but
that's I was going to ask you that they
did they felt that they didn't like the
impression or what would what happened I
don't know maybe maybe they didn't like
it I liked how did you find out that
they weren't going to use your voice I
didn't you just see the movie yeah you
show up and it was like that they don't
even tell you yeah I was always kind of
like weirded out by that but instead of
like getting too weird about it I just
made my own I made us short about Orson
Welles where I did do the voice and I
felt better about it after that oh
really because you liked playing Orson
Welles and you wanted that you wanted
the full portrayal to just kind of exist
yeah yeah yeah were you insulted by it
or is it like hey look he's a real guy
who's it's kind not as insulting if the
real guy's voice is just different than
your voice it means well as an actor you
should be able to if you're going to
take on a role you should be able to do
it a hundred percent and I I I thought
that I could but you know Tim Burton is
Tim Burton he's he's amazing so I'm not
going to challenge him he's awesome
filmmaker I'm not going to question
right his choices so whatever reason he
chose to do that is fine and he is still
a great film do you have a favorite film
maker you've worked because you've
worked with a lot of filmmakers I mean
you know I like I like I have to say
that I know that I just did the Wizard
of Oz but it's the second thing I've
done with tarsem they're more and I
think he's amazing I really do yeah I
think he's an auteur
I think he's not the typical director
yeah it must be tough to start with or
or do Kubrick so early on and then go
because I mean you talk about not a
typical director and then to go kind of
into places where you will find fairly
typical directors right like it can't be
it can't be easy to take direction from
somebody who like like the guy who did
Emerald City or Kubrick or Tim Burton
who are obviously brilliant yeah and
then maybe have to deal with people that
aren't quite as is brilliant well they
all are they all easier than Kubrick
Claire Kubik was very tough and very
specific he was very nice to us -
Matthew and myself and Harless Howard
Matthew Modine myself in arles hair he
was very nice to us we got treated
really well we never got in trouble or
he never used to invite us we used to go
watch movies at his house he Becht any
good project movies for us he had these
two giant projectors in the screening
room and he used to thread the
projectors himself and would you watch
we watched Purple Rose of Cairo
we watched Raging Bull and we watched
one other thing that was amazing
actually that I'd never seen before I
feel like I'm such a phony if I was
watching movies with Kubrick I just be
watching Kubrick the whole time well
make sure I'm a bit of that you reacted
the same way I did it's a card trick yes
amazing yeah the American Raging Bull
it's funny when you watch that you like
you're the only guy - they said who put
on more weight than DeNiro for that role
yeah
which is pretty it's a pretty amazing
accomplishment yeah yeah we have guys we
work with it I've done that but I'm a
particular role um but Vincent D'Onofrio
they they're telling us you have to
leave but it was I do
yeah they had other press your next
interview Emerald City it was really
interesting I didn't know what it was
about I didn't know the name but they
just it's the Vincent D'Onofrio show
they didn't elements know how its read
Mike knew you're the wizard show I am
the way I invented D'Onofrio show I had
no idea what to expect and I and I'm and
I'm watching I'm like oh that's what
this it's a modern day
it is glisten about was really
interesting when you watch it because I
didn't know it was a Wizard of Oz thing
either so it just kind of like Emerald
City is like huh and then I started
watching oh there's a there's a twister
coming her name is Dorothy oh I think I
see where we're going here yeah well you
know it's actually the tone of it the
actual whole show the tone of it is sort
of like that we're obviously you know
it's about Emerald City you know the
iconic musical right yeah but the way
that they wrote it is very interesting
because it's an origin story of all the
characters and Dorothy comes in and
through her eyes you see why everybody
is who they are and how they become who
they are the lie in the Tin Man
you know everything all the witches they
all it's all we use the iconic
characters as metaphors and and then
show you their psychology and how they
become who they are and as these iconic
figures and as you're watching you're
like how okay you're looking like this
gonna be a modern twist on so many of
these things and it was it that was
really cool to like recognizing things
and see how they change it to might feel
like it was shot in 2016 that was kind
of a fun part of watching it too was
seeing like with the flying monkeys but
it was a drone I'm not going to give any
more away but it was it was really
really good and really interesting it's
called Emerald City and it premieres
tomorrow at 9:00 p.m. on NBC Vincent
D'Onofrio thanks for stopping by man
thank you guys and I hope you back